views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of eight news now or next
our media group
there's no magic bullet you're not gonna
find some brand new tax that
that nobody has ever heard of
tonight on politics now making the
budget work
with the legislature just days away
democratic state senator mo dennis tells
us where the money will come from plus
we need to have all branches of the
government we shouldn't have one branch
dictating everything
having more say house senate minority
leader james settlemeyer wants to give
the legislature more power over pandemic
related decisions
by december 31st 1.5
million claims were filed
[Music]
making dieter better recommendations
from the team
tasked with changing our unemployment
system
from eight news now this is politics now
thank you for joining us i'm john
langler the 2021 legislative session
starts on
monday it comes as the state grapples
with a pandemic
massive budget shortfall and sky-high
unemployment
while lawmakers their staff and
journalists will be in carson city
the public can only take part virtually
you can only comment on zoom or other
uh online forms or through email for
example
members of the public will not be
allowed into the capitol building until
vaccines are given to the lawmakers
and staff so what are the top priorities
in this session several lawmakers say
it's economic development and education
last week we interviewed people from the
assembly the leadership
this week we're tackling the senate we
start with democrat mo dennis who is the
president pro temper
let's talk education um the the
funding formula obviously was a has been
a major
issue that you have been touting for for
a long time
what are the chances that that gets
fully implemented
during this session so i mean we're
going to look at that um
we're trying i'm trying to to understand
uh what the governor is proposing
in in his proposal um
it's it's very important for us to
implement this new funding formula it's
transparent
makes it easy for everybody to
understand where the money's going
um and it focuses education funding on
education
so i think we all have that goal to make
sure that that happens and that's what
we're working towards
but in in i guess in the hierarchy of
priorities specific to
education given the circumstances with
the pandemic just getting kids back in
class
where does uh finishing the funding
formula
adjustments where does that fit on your
priority scale
well i think that's the number one thing
we need to do keep in mind the funding
formula
is not about how much money we're
putting into education it's how we
allocate it
and having a transparent um funding
formula
that allows us to i mean even if we're
just looking at it we want to make
adjustments
it's very easy under the new formula to
make those adjustments
how much of a fight over money is there
going to be this legislative session
compared with all other ones it's always
a bit of a dog fight up there there's
not
no endless supplies of funding to go
around but when you when
everyone gets together and you start to
talk um
how much of a scramble is it going to be
well i think
everybody is anticipating that you know
we're not going to have
any extra money and we've got what we
have and i think people are more
understanding as we get up there
i don't think there's a lot of proposals
i don't think people have a lot of
proposals that
that are going to require a lot of extra
money what are some other measures some
other
issues that you hope to tackle or uh put
your support behind
uh when the session starts
well definitely uh one of the things
that uh you know in addition to all the
issues that you know education
and the pandemic has pointed out in
education in inequities
i think economic development needs to be
another huge
issue that we that we need to tackle we
need to find ways to
expand you know the way that we
currently
um bring in revenues for the state
is very limited um there's only certain
ways you can do that so
the only way you're really going to
increase revenues
is to change our economy in a way that
we're bringing in
um additional revenues from you know
we're so dependent on
on tourism gaming and we've got to find
other ways to bring other
industries so that you know when we have
a pandemic like we do
right now tourism is the first thing to
go and it's usually the last thing to
come back
it seems though that nevada needs some
short term
fixes is there anything short term that
the legislature can do
besides wait for federal funding
as far as increasing um right now any
short-term things would have to be
things like
making sure that we're that the internet
for example things that are purchased on
the internet that we're getting those
sales tax revenues
that's something that could be more
immediate
you know any adjustments that we would
want to make
to any of the existing taxes could bring
more
that way but you know this is a tough
time to look at those issues and see
what we can do more
in the immediate so things like you know
trying to figure out ways that we can
save and maybe do things more
efficiently
now senator dennis of course was one of
the driving forces behind the change to
a weighted school funding formula here
in nevada
that's where the money follows the
student instead of being allocated to
specific schools senate minority leader
james settlemyer
also says education is his number one
priority
he wants to make students are back in
class first
your thoughts on how his proposal is
going to
play in the legislature when the rubber
meets the road
i feel that since the party in charge is
also the party the
governor i think that they will go along
with his budget
and i think it'll say along pretty good
and i
worry a little bit about the concept is
very optimistic that we're only going to
be two percent down on revenue
i think as always it doesn't matter what
anyone says
at this point in time it really comes
down to that final economic forum number
because that establishes the amount of
money that we'll have to spend
how much unity you believe there can be
on just a statewide level between
people who are maybe republican and
democrat and then also in the
legislative
session how much unity do you think
there can be that
achieved when you're up there trying to
get laws passed
trying to navigate the budget trying to
work on all these important issues
because i get the sense in your voice
that there's
there's frustration that still lingers
from what we've just been through
people are people they're great the
issue is sometimes that
parties choose to put certain
individuals forth in leadership
positions
that unfortunately sometimes can be
pathologically partisan
and that's the real problem we need to
do what's right for the state of nevada
and as far as the issue of what's
happened in previous sessions
yeah there's some bad blood things were
forced down the minority
party told you're just going to take it
we don't care about you
however if you look at the holistic
approach
95 of bills pass on a bipartisan way
what are some of the other main issues
that you would like to address when
you're
in carson city at the session
big topics there's a lot of things to
deal with we need to get the state back
up and running
education needs to be dealt with
we need the kids back in school
i know that sounds crazy but if you look
across the state we only have one county
that hasn't gone back to school
that's a problem and they're clamoring
that they need to get the shot
well teachers in northern nevada went
back to school without a shot
and so we need to figure out how to get
these kids back
in a productive environment when the
kids aren't in school
it makes it very difficult for the
parents
to go to work every day so to me that's
the main focus
is the education of the children of the
state of nevada and the way to do that
is to get them back into the classrooms
the other thing is i believe we need
some
guard rails on chapter 414 a nevada
revised statute that gives the governor
complete power to do this type of thing
without discussion with the legislature
we need to have all branches of the
government
we shouldn't have one branch dictating
everything it should have to go through
the legislature through the judicial
branches in order to make sure that we
have a balanced
form of government the issue of changing
the funding formula
kind of got hesitated a slowed down
because of the pandemic and a variety of
other things
do you envision that being revisited and
what concerns do you still have
over changing how education is funded
and where the
how the pocket of money is dealt with
well obviously the formula on the budget
and that one was not a republican versus
a democrat issue in any way shape or
form
they did end up being a little bit of
north versus south uh
rural versus rural and that's just a
reality
uh due to mining funds and the way the
constitution was written do i imagine
we're going to have tweaks to it
absolutely every session we've tweaked
with the
amount of money going to education
whether it be rural
whether it be urban whether it's north
versus south
doesn't matter we've always tweaked with
that formula to try to create a better
balance and we will continue to
we also spoke with senator settlemeyer
about how he thinks the
legislative session should run
essentially the way the state is being
run right now
if businesses can have 25 capacity he
believes the legislature should have
people be able to testify in person as
well with that 25 percent capacity
you can watch the full interviews as
well as ones we've done earlier with
assembly speaker jason fryerson
and republican assembly deputy floor
leader tom roberts on eight newsnow dot
com
just look for politics under the news
tab on tuesday the clark county
commission picks replacements for two
open seats in the legislature
they're both going to be democrats and
they have to of course live in the
districts they would represent
this week commissioners revealed who
applied for the assembly district 42
seat in spring valley
that was left open after alex ascepha
resigned
metro police recommended charges against
asepha in a campaign finance scandal but
those charges have not actually been
filed
six people applied for the seat they
include opportunity village executive
tracy marie brown may
and jack abasher iii he owns his company
owned several restaurants
and other commercial real estate in 2019
nevada became the first
state with a female majority legislature
and now it is becoming a female
dominated legislature about two-thirds
of the assembly are women while the
senate is split right down the middle
overall this year's legislature is more
than 60 percent
female coming up next on politics now
fixing unemployment
the legislature looking to make changes
at dieter we're going to take a look at
the recommendations from a task force
trying to get people paid and fight
fraud welcome back
to politics now
[Music]
governor steve sisilak wants to make
sure nevada gets its fair share of
federal grant dollars
he says the state is leaving millions of
dollars on the table every year
during a roundtable discussion local
nonprofits said the biggest hurdle
was knowing what grants they're eligible
for and then applying for them correctly
governor sysolak wants to create a state
office to just do that
this is a change of perspective in terms
of how we do business this isn't a
one-shot deal to try to restore
some cuts that we've got coming up this
session and these are some cuts
if the 711 comes up with a bill that we
can change the infrastructure in the
foundation
to open up the spigot and get more money
coming on a long
term regular basis for you guys to put
out in
the community that's what we're looking
to do
assembly woman danielle monroe moreno is
writing a bill to create
that office it would be a cabinet level
position answering to the governor
another plan is to create funding for
smaller nonprofits to take
grant writing courses over at unlv
a task force looking into nevada's
unemployment system has finished its
work
it was a volunteer role for former
assembly speaker barbara
buckley this week she provided
recommendations for dieter moving
forward while addressing the current
obstacles that it still
faces joe moeller looks at the work that
needs to be done
by december 31st 1.5
million claims were filed thursday deter
announced the rapid response strike
force leader barbara buckley will no
longer be helping the department when
the strikeforce began
there were 245
765 claims in the backlog
thousands of claims still remain in the
backlog with the current processing rate
of 5000 a week the welfare staff
can clear this remainder by february 7th
thousands are still waiting to have
their appeals heard as well something
they say they are getting through and
adding 10 staff to help
next week take the week of january 11th
723 appeals were reviewed
568 were either redetermined
and paid the appeal was withdrawn
or if it was or it was determined not to
be a valid appeal
leaving 155 to be scheduled
when the extension of benefits was added
many people were left without their
money
the department is working on what
extension comes first we are still
working out with the department of labor
what the sequence is
of how you get your p e u c
weeks and then go to state extended
benefit weeks
because we have to get the order right
dieter is updating computer programs
working on phone
problems and implementing new fraud
fighting tools the director says they
know many are falling victim to fraud
especially with the bank of america
debit cards
she says every day they send claims to
the bank to be reinstated
but the bank is now behind we are
working on
resolving that um and my understanding
right now is that bank of america does
have a backlog
in terms of unfreezing cards joe mohler
8 news now
several state lawmakers say modernizing
the computers and software at dieter
this
session is a priority right now there
are four separate bill draft requests
addressing
unemployment in the system here in
nevada coming up next on politics now
will helping the climate hurt jobs
alexander limon will join us to break
down the executive orders
signed by the biden administration this
week you're watching
politics now
[Music]
energy secretary nominee jennifer
granholm says the administration the
biden administration
will focus on green jobs she also told
the senate energy and natural resources
committee that
she opposes using yucca mountain to
store nuclear waste
nevada senator catherine cortez masto
sits on that
committee granholm is the former
governor of michigan
the byte administration says it will
take decisive and immediate action to
combat climate change
the president announced several
executive orders to clean energy and
lower emissions
the bite administration's plan will also
focus on low-income communities across
the country
where high emissions increase asthma and
cancer rates
it creates both a white house
interagency
task force to address environmental
justice
as well as an advisory council it
directs the department of health and
human services to create an
office of climate change and health
equity
the biden team says it will offset job
losses in the oil and gas industry
by transitioning the workforce to the
clean energy sector
our washington dc correspondent
alexander limon joining us now to talk
about
uh the string of executive actions taken
by
president biden since he's taken office
let's start with
climate change several orders that deal
with the environment
although some of them have already
raised concerns including with members
of his own party
yeah president biden released this
massive climate change plan that
included signing those executive orders
and the plan does a lot of things for
example
banning uh oil and gas drilling and
exploration on
federal lands it also creates an
interagency
task force uh to deal with climate
change and
actually a lot of new positions and
offices throughout the general
government
um to deal with climate change and
climate injustice so the vitam team also
really wants to focus on helping
low-income and minority communities
because a lot of times we see
the worst pollution and impacts of
climate change
on those neighborhoods and it's very
hard for them to get out of that
but part of the problem is that this
entire climate change plan is gonna cost
about
two trillion dollars this obviously
coming at a time when we're already
spending so much money dealing with the
pandemic
um and then also there are concerns that
it could cost a lot of
jobs in the oil gas and auto industry
now the
biden administration is trying to push
back on that thing we're already paying
a ton of money to deal with the impacts
of climate change for example the raging
wildfires that get worse and worse
out west every year um and also the
hurricanes that get worse they say it
would actually cost
less money according to biden team to
deal with
trying to mitigate the impacts of
climate change another series of issues
are a couple of them actually the
president signed executive orders
dealing with
uh health care racial equality there's a
lot of them that he signed since he took
office
what are some of the other highlights
and uh how things move forward from here
so basically this was executive order
week every single day president biden
came out and signed executive orders on
one topic or another so
a racial equality that was one day and
he directed this was a big one he
brought
the justice department to phase out and
end contracts with
private for-profit prisons because we
know that the prison system
and especially the for-profit prison
system negatively
impacts and disproportionately impacts
communities of color
um so that was one thing he also
directed the department of housing and
urban development
to try to deal with some of these
historic and systemic issues that we see
that prevent black and
hispanic and other minority communities
from buying their first home and
you know and president biden talked
about you know that prevents them from
building equity and ever being able to
build
generational wealth like we see you know
white counterparts do
and that was alexander limon reporting
from washington dc
coming up next on politics now nevada
doesn't have a lottery
why is that you're watching politics now
[Music]
well there were long lines for powerball
and mega millions jackpots across the
country but
not here in nevada so why doesn't nevada
have
the lottery we certainly have plenty of
other gambling well it was actually
outlawed in the original nevada state
constitution passed in 1864
and since then plenty of bills to remove
that language have been written but
they've all died a very quick
death the closest attempt was in 2009
it was passed by the state assembly but
it failed in the senate
since it's in the constitution this kind
of measure would have to pass
both houses in carson city in two
consecutive sessions
and then get approved in a general
election ballot
it was done through an initiative
petition that would need to go on two
straight
general election ballots essentially
it's a long road
here's a look at what to watch as we
mentioned earlier the 2021 legislative
session starts in carson city on monday
there are new rules because of the
coronavirus people will have to give
their public comment on bills either
online or via a zoom link for now
those links will be on the nevada
legislature webpage
we at a news now we're going to have a
crew in carson city for the beginning of
the session
two members of the legislature still
need to be chosen the clark county
commission votes on replacements for the
state senate district 10 seat
and assembly district 42. that selection
will be on tuesday
both of those seats will go to democrats
that'll do it for us this week here on
politics now thank you very much for
joining us
stay up with us stay up to date with us
on eightnewsnow.com
to check back with you later
[Music]
you